of course I have nothing against the
fact that your boss treats you in a nice
way and so on the problem is if this not
only covers up the actual relationship
of power but makes it even more
impenetrable you know if you have a boss
who is up there the old fashioned boss
shouting at you exerting full brutal
Authority in a way it's much easier to
repel then to have a friendly boss who
embraces you or how us was the last
night with your girlfriend blah blah all
that body stuff where then it almost
appears impolite to protest but I will
give you an example an old story that I
often use to make it clear what do I
mean by this
imagine you or me we are I'm a small boy
it's Sunday afternoon my father wants me
to visit our grandmother let's say my
father is a traditional authority what
would he be doing you probably told me
something like I don't care how you feel
it's your duty to visit your grandmother
be polite to her and so on nothing bad
about this I claim because I can still
repel and so on it's a clear order but
what would a so-called the so called
post modern modern non authoritarian
father do I know because I experienced
it he would have said something like
this you know how much your grandmother
loved you but nonetheless I'm not
forcing you to visit her
you should only visit her if you freely
decide to do it now every child knows
that beneath the appearance of free
choice there is a much stronger pressure
in this second message because basically
your father is not only telling you you
must visit your godmother but you must
love to be
she did it yo he tells you how you must
feel about it it's a much stronger
orders and I think that this is for me
almost a paradigm of modern permissive
Authority this is why the formula of
totalitarianism is not I don't care what
you think just do it this is traditional
authoritarianism the totalitarian
formula is I know better they knew what
you really want and I may appear to be
forcing you to do it but I'm really just
making you do what without fully knowing
you want and so on and so on so in this
sense yes I am horrified by this also
another aspect this new culture of
experts where an injunction is presented
just as a neutral statement for example
one example that I like and let's not
have a misunderstanding here I don't
smoke and I am for punishing tobacco
companies and so on and so on but I'm
deeply suspicious about our phobia about
smoking I don't buy it the disc can be
really justified just based on
scientific knowledge how cigarettes
hurt us and so on and so on because the
my first problem is that most of the
people who oppose smoking then usually
are for legalization of drugs and so on
and so on but my basic problem is this
one look now they found a more or less
solution e cigarettes electronic
cigarettes and I discovered that now I'm
a big American airline companies decided
to prohibit them and it's interesting to
read the reason why the reason it's not
so much that is not yet sure are they
safe or not basically they are the idea
is that if you smoke during the flight a
cigarette you publicly display your
addiction and that it's not a good
pedagogical example for others and so on
and so on I mean I find this a clear
example of how
a certain ethic which is not just
neutral ethics of health but basically I
think it's ethics of don't don't fall
into it don't have a too passionate
engagement remain at the proper distance
control yourself and so on and now I
will shock you to end I think even
racism can be ambiguous here you know
once I made an interview where I was
asked how do we find reactionary racism
you know what much my answer with
progressive racism then what do you mean
of course I didn't mean racism what I
meant is the following things of course
racist jokes and so on can be extremely
oppressive humiliating and so on but the
solution I think is to create an
atmosphere or to practice these jokes in
such a way that they really function as
that little bit of obscene contact which
establishes through proximity between us
and I'm talking from my own past
political experience ex-yugoslavia
I remember when I was young when I met
from other when I met with other people
from ex-yugoslavia public service crowd
Bosnia's and so on we were all the time
take telling dirty jokes about each
other
but not so much against the other we
were in a wonderful way competing who
will be able to tell a national joke
about ourselves this were obscene racist
joke but their effect was a wonderful
sense of shared obscene solidarity and I
have another proof here do you know that
when civil war exploded in Yugoslavia
early 90s and already before in the
eighties ethnic tensions the first
victim were these rocks they immediately
disappeared because people felt very
well that for example what let's say I
visit another country I hate this
politically correct respect ooh
is your food what are your cultural
forums no I tell them tell me a dirty
joke about yourself and we will be
friends and so on it works so you see
this ambiguity that's my problem with
with political correctness no it's just
a form of self-discipline which doesn't
really allow you to overcome racism
it's just oppressed controlled racism
and the same goes here I will tell you a
wonderful story simple once it happened
to me a year ago around the corner here
in the bookstore I was signing a book of
mine two black guys came
african-americans I don't like the term
my black friend also not because for
obvious reasons it can be even more
racist but the point is and they asked
me to sign a book and seeing them there
I couldn't resist the worst racist
remark when I was returning the books to
them I told them you know now I don't
know which one is for whom you know you
blacks like yellow guys you look all the
same they embraced me and they told me
you can call me nigger you know when
they tell you this it means we are
really close they instantly got this
another stupid problem I had at some
talk there was a mutant deaf guy and he
asked if a translator can be there total
and I couldn't resist it in the middle
of the talk in front of two 300 people I
said what are you doing there guys my
idea was if you watched the gestures of
the translator it looked to me as the
same obscene messages or what the guy
laughed so much we become friends not
all and some old stupid lady reported me
for making fun of crippled people it was
so didn't you see that's how I became
friend with a guy but I'm wait a minute
now I'm not an idiot I well aware this
doesn't mean we should just walk around
and humiliate each other it's a great
art how to do it I'm just saying that's
my hypothesis without such an tiny
extreme
of friendly obscenities you don't get a
real contact with another it remains
this cold respect and so on you know we
need this we need this to establish a
real contact this is what is lacking for
me in political correctness and then you
end up in madness like it's not a joke
I checked up with my Australian friends
you know what happened in Perth the West
Coast Australian city it's not a joke
repeated the Opera House they're
prohibited staging of Carmen opera
Carmen you know why because the first
act takes place in front of a tobacco
factory I'm not kidding I'm not kidding
I'm I'm just saying that there is
something so fake about about political
correctness it's I know it's better than
open racism of course but I wonder if it
works because you know I never for
example bought all this permanent
replacement you know niggers are Negros
Negroes are black ok black and African
Americans maybe it's up to them to
decide the only only thing I know is
that when I was in Missoula Montana I
got engaged in a very friendly
conversation with some Native Americans
they hate the term and they gave me a
wonderful reason they told me Native
American and you are cultural Americans
or what we are part of nature they told
me we'd much prefer to be called Indians
at least our name is a monument to white
men stupidity who in India when they
come here and they had such a wonderful
insight into how all this new age
you know we white people
technologically exploit later while
Native relate to nature in a dialogic
way like before they dig into earth they
ask the mountain for permission if
they're mining blah blah
they told me that the research shows
that Native American Indians killed much
more buffalos and burned much more
forests than white people you know why
this was the correct point like the
message was the most racist thing is to
patronizingly elevate us in that you
know primitive organic living together
with modern nature now the Sunda mental
right is to be evil also if we can be
evil why shouldn't they be evil and so
on not so again even with racism one has
to be very precise not to fight racism
in a way which ultimately reproduces if
not directly racism itself at least the
conditions for racism
you